voilà on parlait des conséquences des
événements sur la guerre en Ukraine on
va revenir maintenant c'est difficile à
dire pour l'instant quels sont quels
sont ses effets mais Gulliver crack
bonjour vous êtes notre correspondant
dans le pays la première image à retenir
c'est Hélène ski qui s'entourent de ses
partenaires puisque le président dit
avoir parlé avec Biden et trudo ces
dernières heures c'est ça
oui avec Joe Patton président des
États-Unis Justin Trudeau le Premier
ministre canadien et aussi le président
polonais et puis le ministre ukrainien
de la défense au Lexy resnikov c'est
entretenu avec son homologue américain
aussi je pense qu'il y a eu toute une
série de discussions téléphoniques à
haut niveau puisque l'Ukraine veut
absolument être au centre des
discussions sur ce qui se passe en
Russie et puis à avancer l'argument
qu'elle partage avec des figures combien
de staltenberg de l'OTAN qui est que
cette époque quel qu'on soit l'issue
montre la faiblesse de la Russie que
c'est une opportunité à saisir d'une
part que c'est aussi une source
d'inquiétude puisque cela montre que la
Russie est chaotique que ce n'est pas du
tout un pays avec qui on pourrait mener
des négociations ou considérer comme un
partenaire fiable mais aussi la
narration qui a été la narration de Kiev
depuis très très longtemps
l'argumentaire plutôt qui ne faut pas
avoir si peur de ce que ça de la Russie
que Martine en réalité il est faible
donc je suis sûr que ils ont avancé ce
genre d'arguments là volodime of the LED
qui a aussi mis l'enface sur le fait
qu'il a parlé de la centrale nucléaire
des aporisa aussi avec chacun de ces
leaders avec qui il s'est entretenu
puisque l'Ukraine a très très peur que
les Russes pourraient faire exploser la
centrale les renseignements militaires
Ukrainiens disent avoir des informations
comme quoi les Russes ont plantés des
explosifs et plus Poutine sera désespéré
voilà comment la logique se présente
plus il pourrait être tenté de faire
quelque chose d'extrêmement drastique et
dans l'opinion publique ukrainienne
depuis l'explosion du barrage de carouka
il y a cette peur que les Russes sont
vraiment capables de faire des choses
qui pourraient même être assez
irrationnel ou apparaître comme
irrationnel du point de vue de leur
propre intérêts puisque comme vous le
dit merzelinski ne cesse de le répéter
la radiation ne connaît pas de frontière
néanmoins du livre il y a quelques
bonnes nouvelles à retenir de la part de
l'armée ukrainienne qui revendique
plusieurs avancées même la libération
d'un village c'est dans la région de
doniak
oui ce sont des petites avancées les
Ukrainiens eux-mêmes admettent que la
contre-offensive n'avance pas très
rapidement mais avant tout de même et
aujourd'hui c'est rive no pile qu'ils
ajoutent à la liste de villages libérés
dans la région de donuts c'est un
village un peu à l'ouest des autres
villages qui ont été déjà libérés juste
au sud de Velika nouveau silica hanama
que au total l'Ukraine a libéré plus de
130 km² depuis le début de la
contre-offensive le 5 juin dernier mais
les porte-paroles militaires et les
experts disent que les Ukrainiens
n'observent pas vraiment de changement
dans le comportement des Russes sur la
ligne de front avant-hier et avait des
espoirs que des troupes russes
pourraient être redéployés pour contrer
les forces des Kenny prigogines en
Russie il n'en est rien visiblement pour
le moment il n'y a pas eu de
affaiblissement ni de perte de morale ou
de désarroi en tout cas les Ukrainiens
n'observe rien de la sorte pour le
moment sur la ligne de franchise voilà
les nouvelles du front avec vous
Gulliver